so I realized somewhere around sophomore
year of high school that suddenly way
more people than I wanted found me
annoying that was probably the first
time I was like maybe I was losing like
I remember that I remember early high
school being like wait a minute
they're not highly entertained and
finding this interesting um so I do
remember I think it's DNA I don't know
where I get it I don't but I wouldn't
you said let like I do remember from 12
to 18 it I found my way how to make this
more palpable and I thought I really
owned it and got great in it until I
became more of a public figure and every
time a [ __ ] piece of content on
Facebook goes viral 4000 people say I'm
a [ __ ]
so you know I think that I think that I
try to deploy self awareness as much as
possible and now I'm self aware that 20%
of people on first impact are not going
to like it and so I do think it came
from the lessons of life like I think
one of the things that one has to do is
accept themselves right and I think once
I'm once I did that then it didn't hurt
so much to have 22 out of 10 people not
like it because the cool thing with me
is I also have 3 out of 10 people that
like it so much and think it's the
coolest thing they've ever seen and just
play it out and for me because I know
I'm grounded in very good truths and
principles I get a second at-bat at it
which is it's so rewarding for people
that thought you were a douchebag to
turn and become an advocate I would tell
you probably the 50 biggest advocates I
have on social initially hated me